- [Voiceover] Seven, six,
five, four, three, two, one.
(funky music)
- Hi, my name is Lynn Root.
I am the Software Engineer
here at Spotify, and I will
be the first to admit that I
often take for granted the
reliability of the Internet.
The sheer amount of
information zooming around the
Internet is astonishing. But
how's it possible for every
piece of data to be
delivered to you reliably?
Say you want to play a song from Spotify.
It seems like your computer
connects directly to
Spotify's servers, and
Spotify sends you a song
on a direct, dedicated line.
But actually, that's not
how the Internet works.
If the Internet were made of
direct, dedicated connections,
it would be impossible
to keep things working as
millions of users join,
especially since there is no
guarantee that every wire and computer is
working all the time.
Instead, data travels on
the Internet in a much less
direct fashion.
- Many, many years ago,
in the early 1970s,
my partner, Bob Kahn,
and I began working on
the design of what we
now call the Internet.
Bob and I had the responsibility
and the opportunity
to design the Internet's
protocols and its architecture.
So, we persisted in participating
in the Internet's growth
and evolution for all of this time,
up to, and including, the present.
The way information gets
transferred from one computer
to another is pretty interesting.
It need not follow a fixed path.
In fact, your path may
change in the midst of a
computer-to-computer conversation.
Information on the Internet
goes from one computer
to another in what we call
a packet of information,
and a packet travels from
one place to another on
the Internet a lot like how
you might get from one place
to another in a car, depending
on traffic congestion or
road conditions, you might
choose or be forced to take
a different route to get
to the same place each time
you travel.
And just as you can
transport all sorts of stuff
inside a car, many kinds of
digital information can be
sent with IP packets, but
there are some limits.
What if, for example, you
need to move a space shuttle
from where it was built to
where it will be launched?
A shuttle won't fit in one
truck, so it needs to be broken
down into pieces, transported
using a fleet of trucks.
They could all take different
routes, and might get to
the destination at different
times, but once all the pieces
are there, you can reassemble
the pieces into the
complete shuttle, and
it'll be ready for launch.
On the Internet, the
details work similarly.
If you have a very large
image that you want to send
to a friend or upload to a
website, that image might
be made up of tens of billions
of bits of ones and zeroes,
too many to send along in one packet.
Since it's data on a
computer, the computer sending
the image can quickly break
it into hundreds or even
thousands of smaller parts called packets.
Unlike cars or trucks, these
packets don't have drivers,
and they don't choose their
route. Each packet has
the internet address of
where it came from and where
it's going. Special
computers on the Internet,
called routers, act like
traffic managers to keep the
packets moving through
the networks smoothly.
If one route is congested,
individual packets may
travel different routes
through the Internet,
and they may arrive at the
destination at slightly
different times, or even out of order.
- So, let's talk about how this works.
As part of the Internet
Protocol, every router
keeps track of multiple
paths for sending packets,
and it chooses the
cheapest available path for
each piece of data, based on destination
IP address for the packet.
"Cheapest," in this
case, doesn't mean cost,
but time and non-technical
factors such as politics
and relationships between companies.
Often the best route for data
to travel isn't necessarily
the most direct. Having
options for paths makes the
network fault tolerant,
which means the network can
keep sending packets, even
if something goes horribly,
horribly wrong. This is the
basis for a key principle of
the Internet, reliability.
Now, what if you want to request some data
and not everything is delivered?
Say you want to listen to a song.
How can you bee 100%
sure all the data will be
delivered so the song plays perfectly?
Introducing your new best friend, TCP,
Transmission Control Protocol.
TCP manages the sending and
receiving of all your data
as packets. Think of it like
a guaranteed mail service.
When you request a song on your device,
Spotify sends the song
broken up into many packets.
When your packets arrive,
TCP does a full inventory
and sends back acknowledgements
of each packet received.
If all packets are there,
TCP signs for your delivery,
and you're done.
(upbeat music)
If TCP finds some packets are missing,
it won't sign. Otherwise, your
song wouldn't sound as good,
or portions of the song could be missing.
For each missing or incomplete packet,
Spotify will resend them.
Once TCP verifies the delivery
of many packets for that one song request,
your song will start to play.
(upbeat music)
What's great about the
TCP and router systems is
they're scalable. They can
work with eight devices or
8,000,000,000 devices. In fact,
because of these principles
of fault tolerance and redundancy,
the more routers we add,
the more reliable the Internet becomes.
What's also great is we
can grow and scale the
Internet without interrupting
service for anybody using it.
- The Internet is made of
hundreds of thousands of
networks and billions
of computers and devices
connected physically. These
different systems that make up
the Internet connect to
each other, communicate with
each other, and work together
because of agreed upon
standards for how data is
sent around on the Internet.
Computing devices, or
routers along the Internet,
help all the packets make
their way to the destination
where they're reassembled,
if necessary, in order.
This happens billions of
times a day, whether you and
others are sending an
email, visiting a webpage,
doing a video chat, using a
mobile app, or when sensors
or devices on the Internet
talk to each other.